yeah yeah yeah Oh Oh guys [ __ ] all right
are you ready I'm ready babe all right
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
your favorite podcast you know the name
[Music]
okay Chris singing Mike what you got I
got um I don't know I'm not really good
singer I love Whitney Houston Oh - this
this sounds like what is this sound like
Heavy D I don't know who this is this is
West Coast Ace of Base I saw the sign
[Music]
okay there we go ladies and gentlemen
and welcome back to riffing with Griffin
and today's guest they're very funny the
talented the the rising star you'd have
to say your last name cuz I wanted I
don't wanna say it wrong Chris de
Stefano this Stefano lady's number Chris
de Stefano Chris Edie also known as
Chrissy drip drop I've been saying your
name wrong for the longest time I've
been like teasing that you're gonna be
on the podcast on my thing like yeah
Chris just Asano is coming on like you
probably get that a lot
all the time and then you know obviously
as a comedian Mike DeStefano who passed
away a few years ago so a lot of times
in New York all his old friends you know
the Colin Quinn's and all the Rye Rye
Rye don't call me Mike still and I'm
like it's Chris and then like a but Mike
DeStefano that's like you we liked him
better than you so he's dead so we're
just gonna call you Mike and hope that
you dying he comes back so originally
from New York obviously Brooklyn New
York baby I currently live in Bay Ridge
which is a very old-school New York
neighborhood yeah just a nice it's a
nice it's a nice change of pace
are you really because here's the thing
um first I mean entertainment I'm you
know liberal you're more liberal anyway
so I am and and it's like you know some
parts of Brooklyn have gotten so soft
where it's like everyone's like
one plant and papers drawers which is
fine but it's like first world problems
where when you go to Bay Ridge it's a
nice melting pot because you have you
have a nice Muslim community that and
some of them and the FB it's interesting
cuz you have you have Muslims who will
go into pizzerias with full you know ha
jobs on and then you'll have the Italian
boy Paulie walnuts the actor you know
Tony Sirico the guy who played pulling
Watson as opposed right lives three
blocks away from me he'll go into Muslim
bakeries and get goods from there and
it's this nice melting pot where you
have like two groups of people that like
are living in harmony but they're both
like set in your ways like what in the
same in the same day you had November
whatever whenever Trump on the election
i whatever date that was on that day you
had a bakery on Third Avenue and 91st
Street giving out Trump giving out free
black and white cookies because Trump
had one and then on the middle of that
block you know the the Muslim community
you had the FBI came and raided and they
got a guy who was wanted for terrorism
and then a little bit like two blocks
down you had somebody who had had gotten
to some like big domestic dispute and
held a woman had was like holding her
kids hostage or something like this is
all where you're from this is all I'm
from on the on the same block was
holding her kids hostage and this is the
melting pot this is another pot was
holding our kids hostage because um
Hillary had lost and she thought that
she don't want her children to go into
Trump's new America so that was all in
the same block yet a terrorist people
giving out black and white cookies to
trump one and then people were
barricading their children in the house
cuz Trump because Hillary lost you know
you know I'm surprised
cuz when you just at first glance right
someone would look at you they would see
like they're like you know the the
swoopy hair right the tattoos yeah and
they'd be like gay man well I mean well
that was that's option B I was gonna say
that you you wouldn't come across as
like a super liberal you thought you've
can't you consider yourself like real
liberal or I consider myself a gray zone
person I I've only voted Democrat in any
election I've been able to vote in I've
also I'm one of
those guys where it's like in I think
inevitably I live in the gray area my
father was like an actual criminal like
a for-real like criminal or uh I don't
think he was in the Mafia but he got
swooped up in mafia organized related
stuff and got was thrown in and out of
jail so one of those like wiseguy kind
of guys he was wiseguy adjacent right
right yeah why he wasn't a made man but
yeah yeah he was a wise ish guy and then
my mother graduated from Columbia
University so an Ivy League school and
extremely liberal wade was reaching up
women's studies oh yeah well I tell a
story on stage but they actually truth
they met at a walkathon and my mother
was walking in the walkathon raising
money for like cancer and other great
things that my dad was doing community
service on the side of the walkathon
with a walkathon when he was like in an
orange like picking up garbage and
flirted with her ass she walked by and
was like following her always picking up
the trash and he was like let me just
please give me a number give me a number
she said she told him her numbers she's
like if you can remember it call me when
you get out and he says he got out like
three or four weeks later and remember
the number and called her he said he
like asked his friend for a pen and
wrote it down he as I couldn't wait to
call him up he was in jail doing a
community service on the sauce like that
halfway house but she knew right well
yeah I mean you're their orange jumped
yeah I mean you're like you know you
know everybody knows like you know they
have them in uniform yeah but so you had
to go back to that halfway house and he
got out like three weeks so it's like
your mom sort of made good choices yeah
well she made good choices she well she
made one really bad choice because my
father's nickname is Tony balls so it's
like that's you know my mother graduated
from an Ivy League school when did she
find that out like what in the dating
process when did she find that day he
was Tony balls going it could've been in
the first week that might be like I
don't know if I want to continue this
well here's here's what like the apple
doesn't fall far from the tree and what
I believe like you don't when it comes
to nature and there's just something
deeper than I don't think we understand
so what happened was is my mother you
know was young she was 21 years old very
religious woman very smart got it's kind
of
wooed by my dad they wound up conceiving
me on the second date oh wow
but because my mother was like and then
my mother that get bad decisions I know
yeah so they even have condoms in
1983-84
my dad wasn't using them man yeah
neither was your mama both yes oh my dad
so so like whatever six weeks later my
mom found out she was pregnant was like
we need to get married because you know
very Cowie yeah back then back then so
they got married had me my mother
divorced my father immediately and then
my just immediately cause I got I'm not
good one
cuz the thing is like as you're pregnant
like she found that as a nickname was
Tony balls but she was already pregnant
with me so it's like now you're stuck by
the way I also understand who she was
going to Columbia you said right yes
grass you know in the Columbia and she
woke up from this haze like what the
[ __ ] did I do
I just got pregnant by like a pseudo
monitor yeah who was in jail I have to
tell people we've been dating and we're
getting me yeah but and it's interesting
enough my mother's father my grandfather
my biological grandfather was a cop and
didn't know for sure but had thought
that a couple years earlier he had
arrested my father for some petty type
of haha so he was always like you look
familiar my dad was like I don't know
what that I don't know I don't think so
sir I have your daughter pregnant but
well I don't know where you could know
me from anything my mother's like I
think he arrested him and you never want
to tell me but um but so so anyway so
they get divorced my father's a great
father really really great dad still to
this day just a great great great dad
but fast forward you know and my
mother's whole my whole upbringing she
was like you're not gonna sound like
your father you're not gonna act like
your father
you're gonna pronounce your R's you're
not gonna get involved in the streets
you know because it's like you know
you're gonna say water not water you
know so she was like cuz my dad's like
oh sorry
okay just move up just a little bit oh
yeah yeah you can yeah so you can like
move back there you go so my dad's like
a stereotypical like New York [ __ ] guy
and and so so my whole childhood my
mother always had me in extracurricular
activities playing sports went all the
way through graduate school got a
doctorate degree because my mother's
very intelligent you will not stop at
undergrad you're gonna go through
graduate school
what you wanted so all these things do
it and I never never got in trouble
never made any mistakes and my mother
was always like you know make sure that
you know that you find a girlfriend and
you know you guys get married and you
have this whole life and all these
things that use pushing me through
school and and all I did was do the
right thing fast forward 30 years old
second day and I go on with this girl
get her pregnant now I have a four year
old daughter and so it's like my mother
could Simba yeah I was so funny too cuz
like my dad is just like such my dad
like at what what did he say to that
when that when all this happened you
come to your dad and go guess what I did
what did he go did he go was he happy or
was he what was it response he literally
he was y'all I gotta give him credit he
was because you know again second date I
barely know this girl like my mother
hung up the phone on me didn't want to
talk to me for two weeks my hand she
tried her best man my work 20-something
years yeah you not to be your father I
know I just became my father and my
aunt's were like what an idiot
but my dad when I told him I was like
hey you know I really [ __ ] up I was
like I was like I really messed up dad I
was like and I was like I'm sorry I was
like I got this girl pregnant and I
don't know her and we're gonna have the
baby and I'm just sorry like that it
happened this way he was like I don't
know why you're apologizing or saying
you're sorry so first of all
congratulations right he said it's a
it's a beautiful thing he said we're
gonna make we're gonna raise this baby
if she doesn't want to do it if you
don't want it we're gonna raise this
baby so he's like stop he said stop
saying you're sorry right now he's like
I know he's are you saying you did you
know your mother he was like your
mother's good cuz the thing is I called
my dad first yeah and my dad because my
dad knew right away he said well we're
gonna have to figure out a way how to
tell your mother cuz cuz you know they
would cuz my dad's been remarried 25
years my stop but they have a
relationship right they just through you
kinda well now they do right my dad and
mom are very close now because they're
both grandparents and I have to tell
them about you like listen there's gonna
be no more bickering [ __ ] you guys I
don't want that energy around my child
right so so so they said so they're very
good cope very good grandparents and my
my dad his wife my step
and my mom all raised all do a great job
of being great grandparents to my
daughter now but at that time but you
know they still there a relationship was
on ice a little bit my dad and my mom
kind of always didn't my dad always
loved my mom was always like listen you
know you dad is the mother of my child
so I'll always love and respect and
protect her my there was instances where
my father beat up my mother's boyfriends
like it was kind of like wild at times I
could tell those stories too um it's
kind of like nuts but my dad um uh said
to me when he was like you know
congratulations we're gonna figure this
out he said we got it you do not tell
your mother though he said you got to
listen to me now Chrissy he goes call me
Chrissy because you're Ella's to me now
Chrissy you can't tell your mother and
they'll never forget I'll never forget I
told my father I was in the parking lot
of side splitters comedy club in Tampa
Florida when I found out yuck nightmare
yeah some tooth wish knowing we were
staying at the condo or did he put you
in a [ __ ] hotel come on dude in the
condo half the room stalled somebody's
tooth in the sink at the time that guy's
a piece of work
Oh disgusting he was like proud of the
night before he was like I knocked a
woman out in the parking lot last night
I'm like York this is great happy to be
here yeah so um so I'm telling my dad
and he goes um he was you can't tell
your mother he goes do me a favor we're
gonna have to wait about two months to
tell your mother he said you're gonna
need to introduce this girl to your
mother tomorrow but you can't tell if
she's pregnant for about two three
months and I said why I said why
wouldn't I just say it immediately he
goes ninernet no he goes what you gotta
do he said you gotta introduce you
introduce this woman to your mother
cuz you got to basically impregnate your
mother with the idea of this woman being
impregnated he said you know what I'm
saying and I'm like uh kind of he goes
listen you gotta go to three months let
this woman fall in love let your mother
fall in love with this woman
yeah and then she's around he's already
impregnated with the idea of this woman
she loves this woman what and then boom
you tell her and by the way she's
impregnated three four months in he said
that's what she do would I know you
didn't do that I didn't do that because
I am a mama's boy and I started to cry
piece of [ __ ] like what yeah why would
you yeah
what happened literally my crust your
mother's soul dude all my dad I know all
my dad does is yelling because my dad's
like a tough guy and I'm like because I
was raised mostly by my mom like even
during Christmas time my dad ate not
like half a tray of lasagna six cannolis
he's diabetic
six cannolis half a tray lasagna like
two pounds of penne Bobtown all I said
as a caring son I was like dad you gotta
slow down
you got the diabetes he goes oh I didn't
know I had a gay son
it's just shoveling penne vodka deep so
that's the kind of dad I have so he was
like trying to talk to me father's son
and I just go and tell my mom yeah and
he's like you [ __ ] idiot yeah cuz
then my mother immediately calls him and
he gets I never forget I had a call from
my dad Tuesday two missed calls in row
and then text call me and he's like you
told your mother you dummy
wait did you rat your dad out I knew
about my dad up but I just couldn't hold
it in okay okay no my dad no let's see
that's the thing with my father my
father's number what my father told my
four-year-old daughter who's in [ __ ]
in preschool come out route out rat out
her friends that's the number one thing
she should never be doing is ratting her
friends cuz she'll come in and their
home
this little boy did this to me is like
why are you being a rat why are you
being around this is like a show like
Sopranos the Degrassi year yeah yeah so
he always would tell me cuz we would
always he would take me like I remember
we will go to Yankee Stadium or when my
father would come pick me up for the
weekends like my mother was like no soda
no sowed he's not allowed to have soda
and as soon as we returned the corner
you know he'd give me Mountain doing
like the worst [ __ ] cuz he's like you
know whatever I'm he was the worst
I guess yeah give us a worst but
simultaneously the best you know and so
my father was always the same thing he
would take me to the racetrack but we
weren't you know being around his
gambling friends he's like all we're
gonna you know tell your mother we went
to the zoo you know like things like
that a woman would go to Yankee games so
what you're saying is your father
basically was undermining everything
your mother did everything you got a
chick every time I forget I grew where I
grew up in Ridgewood by Seneca Avenue
that's where my house was every time we
would get to the corner of my where my
block is and Seneca Avenue he would walk
me there and then and walk across the
street into my mother's house he would
always say what what I'm you know
whatever we would do he would be like
remember don't tell your mother like so
there was so many times like we're not
gonna tell your mother about this so I
never ratted my dad out I just when she
got pregnant I was think so like I kind
of like needed my mom cuz I was so
nervous right about everything I was
like and then she hung up the phone on
me and didn't talk to me for two weeks
but then she came around and it has been
the best grandma yeah well because she
the thing about it is I get it cuz she
made it work well she probably thought
to herself okay I'm an I'm an I'm mad
and now she was like okay I went through
this let me help my kid yeah you know go
through what I went through and then
maybe you you you're gonna break the
cycle it was funny too because my kid's
mom is beautiful Donnie knows a
beautiful beautiful girl she's very
Latino Puerto Rican girl from Brooklyn
my mother's like an articulate white Ivy
League woman so I bring home my baby
mama and Rosie Perez yeah she has a
tattoo winter tit my mother just goes
when you wish I want a Fanta Fanta my
mother I'll never forget I'm like mom
this is my girl and my mother just took
a deep breath she took a sip of Pinot
Grigio and she was like let's go in the
living room she tried to blow it out but
now but you know what I gotta be honest
with you having number one when it comes
to mixed-race babies cuz you know my
daughter is latina oh oh that's what
that's what nature wants the healthiest
immune systems are people with mixed
races nature wants you to funk outside
your race so stop [ __ ] having sex
with your race let's get let's get
global you know that you didn't say that
with like enough passion that I believe
you know I wanna see man for me it's
always been the Latinas they [ __ ] get
me at every turn I'm always like most
like I'm not a sex out of come out of
sex second then I'll just see an ass on
my comments it's like I want to put my
head in that empanada ass
what are you are you Mick black white
mix mix okay very mixed you know guy
just I have a mixed origin and so I
don't worry about it because I always
say people want to know what you are so
they can know how to hate you do you
have kids oh they know I'm gonna put put
you in a box but I'm close my girl and I
were like I'm ring shopping or good I
should say she's ring shop yes that's a
good big announcement I'm ring shopping
but you know I see this great origin
story I love all that and now here you
are as a comedian and like you know
you're out here like I think you're
doing comedy right now at a time that is
like this is like the gold rush of like
YouTube and social media and podcasting
and it's like this weird thing how is it
affected what you do right now well I
mean even now me coming out here to LA I
mean I made a trip out here solely to do
podcast you know your podcast Theo von
the fighter and the kid to be a guest on
those pushes my career forward yeah it's
crazy so much more then I'm also doing
Jimmy Kimmel on Thursday night doing
stand-up on the show and I'm looking
forward to it I'm excited about it and
but I but I'm really focused on this
yeah I don't you say you don't it's such
a weird thing I'm not saying [ __ ] that
I'm gonna do it and give it 100% but
it's like I'm not expecting that to do
anything for my career I'm expecting
this to like you know when I got tickets
and this is what it is and I just feel
like it gives our fans an opportunity to
like really get to know us and be in our
ear for being their ear direct to
consumer direct to consumer you know and
we can like be ourselves and I feel like
thank God we have this outlet it's like
very cathartic to like talk about
whatever [ __ ] thing is happening in
the news that we're like yo that's not
really like that and we can just have an
opinion on it where you know 20 years
ago we wouldn't like our only outlet
would have been going on The Tonight
Show where you have five minutes and you
have to be clean and play pretend the
whole time we're now we could be like
hey here's the real [ __ ] and I feel like
the people the public is responding to
that in a good way so the internet like
I've had an hour special on Comedy
Central I've done David Letterman I've
been in sitcoms some small parts yeah
none of it I was selling no tickets
until last year when I came out here in
LA and I did the O Vaughn's podcast Bert
Kreischer is podcast and in New York I
did Andrew Schultz and girls got to eat
and then my career changed you know for
me yes
where I need to be but I mean I'm
selling more tickets than I ever have in
my whole life a zhing and it's just
because of the podcast and the internet
and I put something out I told the story
about what happened to me on 9/11 and I
put it on YouTube I stand up bitter that
yeah I saw that the other day and it
went got like one it has like 1.5
million views and that also so it's like
you could have given me the TV show you
could have given me all that I would
have never sold tickets that's all I
care about is longevity I was on TV for
13 years right and like people just they
don't associate that you're a comic
right when you do you know even a comedy
you know workaholics yeah yeah because
they were like oh you just an actor or
they don't they don't associate that
you're doing comedy so it means that you
do stand-up they completely separate so
you didn't see a spike in your tickets
alcoholics but now you do cuz your
podcast yeah exactly but the other thing
about workaholics is those were like
college kids they don't got money they
were thrown out they don't know how to
go out and have a good time right you
know they were just like it was only
Adam that was going out and doing
college gigs and like you know he was
the one that was really getting people
to come but for me it was like oh it's
the weird guy from workaholics over
economic you know or they expect that
person when you go when I'm on stage
they expect like how come you're not
acting like Montez you know what I mean
God interesting yeah yeah I guess
because yeah like that's why with this
podcast it's like if they know Eric and
they want forever yeah yeah but also
like it's weird how like you know I'm
realizing that you gotta like I'm still
trying to find out who my audience is or
how to reach my audience so you do like
weird things sometimes like I've been
doing these green screen videos yeah you
know like I'll put myself at other
peoples podcast like Androids
add your santino a Bobby Lee stutter on
a podcast you know so sometimes I'll
just add myself in the middle of their
podcast while they're talking about
something and I'll just like make fun of
whatever it'll air but it's amazing I
people go oh we love that you should do
more of that or like you know whatever
this thing might be that but I realize
now it's just I'm just gonna have fun
right have fun on your social media
that's it and then like share that fun
with people and it's just like with the
pocket I do the podcast really for me
you know like that's what I saying and I
rap and I do all kinds of crazy stuff
that's what I was gonna say and that's I
feel like when I even when I came in
here when you're doing it you know you
got the music on the iPhone
and you set all this up yourself is like
I was like oh this this is a passion
behind this guy wants to do here you're
now trying to get I mean the fans and
money are coming but that's secondary
the passion is first witness you know
yes yeah which I um I can see very well
and that's probably what your fans here
right right I mean you know what I do
get because when I first started doing a
podcast I'll be like how man does sound
like this echo sound you know what I
mean
yeah I'll say something about it and
then like there's people like this is
how you fix it you do this this and this
and then all people are like
acknowledged like yo man the status
sounded better since you started in this
like huh I'm doing and then I get I get
resumes in my peel box from people who
are like I want to be your intern I want
to be your nerd I want a hell yeah so I
got this kid who helps me with the
Instagram posts from the podcast and
it's just it's very fascinating how
people get so invested you know and so I
just like I just started doing these um
I get these like meals today was the
first day I tried it it was a place
called Sun basket they're not even
really a sponsor I want hey you know I
mean but you know I used to get like
freshly sure and it you ever heard of
that you know yeah but the microwave
meals and I loved it it could use
smaller portions you do start to I was
starting to lose weight but the delivery
people are pieces of [ __ ] man right they
were leaving the boxes on the street and
[ __ ] like it's just like they're so
[ __ ] lazy right now so I got this new
word called Sun basket but yet to cook
the food yourself okay so today I was
like I made this shrimp dish it from
scratch right and I was filming it and I
was like oh I can eat people now people
are like you should do a cooking thing
and it's just amazing how they just want
to see like you know as long as you make
things fun they'll appreciate and I feel
like more than ever I mean how could you
me do comedy what 1528 yeah yeah almost
22 almost 20 years
so I'm 10 years in and even I can tell
not in the 10 years that I've been doing
it not this is by far the most that
comics can help other comics is right
now I'm literally no which means a
director or a producer those people are
great no but literally you can help me
so much more than my agent can then some
director can that some writer can it's
like we can all help each other so like
the camaraderie and nepotism amongst us
all is good and I can see it's making
like people in the industry a little
scared they're like hey oh yeah that's
why I almost
that's why I almost think like why when
people like Oh sitcoms it they're so
corny now you have to be so um you have
to be corny you have to be so squeaky
clean that's not what people want I
think they're saying the network's it
comes like well if we don't make this we
have to have something yeah that's a
bleeped just said you can curse and do
whatever then yeah you're gonna take
that from us - okay devil's advocate
though I hear what you're saying on that
but I only disagree on one way that you
know we also live in very sensitive
times right now you know this is a very
sensitive time it's very so there for
like for instance I don't know if I show
like workaholics can be made right now
like if they were coming out with a show
that was like you know well you know
it's like TNA and like you know drugs
and alcohol and I was kind of they might
be like oh we have to hold off on this
because of how society is thinking about
stretcho
so I think that network TV I mean
they're still catering to middle America
they're still catering to like you know
the Big Bang Theory crowd and they want
you they want it to be run and then they
still have this idea that people only
want to see pretty people on TV but and
I think that the problem is look if it's
CSI
yes I want my I want my blood expert on
CSI to be a hot blonde yeah okay yeah I
don't need it you know you don't because
this is this is fantasy right i watch
the ugly [ __ ] I'll go to the DMV okay
there's regular chick right there this
is a whole story but when I'm looking at
TV I get it so that's why I'm not number
one on the call sheet but I'll be like
silly guy number five Number six number
seven all I'm trying to say is that they
comedy they keep trying to make comedy
pretty and it just yeah it can't all be
pretty now and that's why I think it's
not real yeah PPP because and look at
the success of most of there's a lot of
ugly [ __ ] comedians now real
successful but they keep telling us that
like they keep trying to make it out
like not again but listen I get it
though it's an image business not a good
looking guy we shouldn't care of
yourself you got your hair swooped in a
yeah I get it that is a part of your
business right you know what I mean but
for me it's like I gotta be funny
there's no wiggle room for me yeah you
know listen I do all right you know
mean I'm confident I got a very
beautiful girl that's gonna be my
fiancee you know but but in terms of
like mass appeal I get it you have to so
there's like there's a give-and-take so
like if we're on a sitcom together you
know it's gonna be the Chris show yeah
and I'm gonna got it comes in be a great
show but yeah I think you need a balance
of that and there's so many of these
shows I look on it's like they think
that like what we're gonna have the
ethnic guy the cute ethnic guy will
represent the diversity of it it's like
no man so anyway to get back to it to
bring it I'm just saying I think that
we're gonna get back to where we want
comedy to be like Something About Mary I
like just what happened to the raw in
your face right that stuff I think we're
still a little scared right I think
Hollywood is scared right now push that
envelope and I think I think - but
you're seeing like all these people like
go around yeah now what you could never
do that
no jokes is a big example that because
Schulz he put two middle fingers up to
Hollywood oh you'd want you don't want
to [ __ ] with me okay yeah i'ma [ __ ] with
myself and then he's putting out some of
the best content I think what the only
space that I think you could still get
away with a lot of [ __ ] is animation
like South Park I mean those guys have
always been able to say whatever and I
think about a grandfather didn't though
they are well in a way you'd here's one
bring it up so I had a sitcom pilot with
CBS it didn't get picked up but I mean
they made me dude
look like a [ __ ] corn while I was in
cargo pants oh you know like a blue
sweatshirt my dad was played by Chas
palm and Terry hoop from a Bronx Tale
right I had him saying shucks it's like
this guy [ __ ] knows actual mafia
murderers they're not saying shucks this
character that I wrote is not a shucks
guy but they were like you know people
in Iowa like shocks but this I have an
animated show in development right now
with Comedy Central and they'll script
that they're letting me go with is like
[ __ ] wild right you know like they're
letting me let my dad make fun of me
because I eat blueberry yogurt you know
like they're doing [ __ ] like that when
I'm like wow am I gonna be able to say
that's nailing it's animation and it's
cable so yeah just do it so it's kind of
cool I mean it probably won't get I'm
Kristy I have eight five at eight pilots
none of them have made it so I'm Chrissy
one and done Chrissy pilot so I don't
expect
this to go but it it is cool to just at
least somebody at least that only people
that I've worked with in cable that are
like yeah man whatever you you tell us
what you think is funny push it as far
as you want to go and we'll see if we
can get it through well I think it's
going back to that I mean I'm which I
think is the smart thing to do it's like
this is a weird thing though like people
like you for a certain thing right they
watch your standup they've been watching
you they're following you and they know
you as this and then network television
goes let's take that guy and his fans
and make him this and then people are
watching and they go who the [ __ ] is
that yeah why what why did he do that
and then and then it doesn't work and
they don't wonder what any wonder why it
doesn't when I take so many licenses
like so many like cooks in the kitchen I
know this might be like very inside
comedy but it's just a point for a
bigger thing where it's like people
don't wanna people are so scared of what
the truth is now because of like
offending people my real story that I
pitched then I talking about comedy is I
met my kids mom okay we got into like we
would argue a lot she was kind of like
wild and crazy we broke up she had a
child from a previous relationship
before year-old someone I met her right
uh you know and it's like the story was
about me trying to raise this you know
have a baby with a woman I didn't even
know trying to learn a new culture the
Puerto Rican culture and help raise and
and be a stepdad with his father was
still in the picture so trying to juggle
all that right by the time and that's
what we wrote that was a comedy about
and that's what they loved then by the
time you film this sitcom you were a
priest
yeah literally it's my show if they
called the name could we name the
character the female lead is e the name
of the show is is e in me so my name
isn't even in my own [ __ ] show
anymore so they got rid of my name
number two and then they changed that
they changed the lead from Puerto Rican
to Colombian for no reason because the
actress who played it was Colombian and
it's like that's fine but it's like it's
[ __ ] it the shows about being Puerto
Rican yeah that's a New York thing but
it was fine whatever and then yet they
made me the truth is the comedy is about
her being crazy and me being like I need
to get away from this woman but they
made me a little passive-aggressive
[ __ ] and her being the strong female
lead
woman and then they took her having an
another child
uh-huh out of the equation because
they're like we don't want it to seem
like she's having she has all these baby
daddies I'm like she has two baby
daddies and that's the truth right what
are you saying like you're you're
actually being more offensive but you're
saying oh what and nobody can have
nobody can have two kids two different
guys so they don't even realize he's
just drinking the blood of [ __ ] small
children and doing whatever but I mean
this is what the world we live in like
whatever is happening right now I mean
listen man to me to movement had an
effect on how Dora where I was like that
that's where they went with they were
like let's make a you know we can't have
another white male star so let me make
it and make him me yeah yeah and then
and then they just went with it like
that so I mean I get it I understand but
I just don't think it's short-sighted in
a sense of like they've lost the essence
of what well that's what I love about
being a comedian and and stand up
because stand up is yet TV shows and
movies they can pick who they want for
whatever reason they want they want to
represent this group in that whatever
whatever but when it comes to stand up
when you just put the stand ups on stage
you got to be funny nobody cares if
you're you know a transgender Eskimo
nobody cares
it's like are you funny if you're funny
we're gonna laugh at you yeah if you're
not funny you're gonna sit there and
bomb with like a white guy like a black
guy you're gonna [ __ ] eat it
everybody bombs the same everybody bombs
the same you know it's kind of like when
a famous person comes to a club and like
you know they're gonna go up and you
know do it guest said they get a minute
of oh my god wow I can't believe it and
then it turns into like this [ __ ]
funny [ __ ] stink bomb oh it's great
to watch somebody just eat their dick
ice comics I was talking about this on
Theo show as comics I think that's the
fun it one of the only thing that can
genuinely make me heartfelt laugh is
watching a good comedian bomb not a bad
communica it's like but even better is a
good comedian that's your friend that
one oh yeah just eat in their balls in
front of like a packed crowd and then
just trying to do it or get out of look
we're from shut up [ __ ] bomb and yeah
and I just you know I
do you think there's like um so you're
from the east coast yeah now when you
come to the west coast to do comedy you
like what do you find the differences I
don't find your crowds is it like you
know what are you what are you well I
think like there's little adjustments
that I have to make like I talk a lot
about you know my circumstances which
are having a Puerto Rican kid and I know
sometimes it's not as identifiable out
here they're like we know about Puerto
Ricans but it's not that many out here
so I have to change a little bit of that
but as far as the thing same things that
they laugh at in New York or wherever
I'm at the lab found and in LA I think
in the comedy club the only thing I
would say is sometimes I see a little
bit more what I think when I look out at
a crowd at an LA crowd is like a little
bit like they all want to do what we're
doing but they're like watching us as
they're not enjoying it they are
enjoying it but they're also thinking
about I wish I I want to be a in that
show half the room has a head shot where
New York it's just like it's just guys
who just finished a shift or guys out
with their wives they have no aspiration
to be an entertainment they just want to
laugh because they want to forget about
their life for an hour and I know that
LA has majority of that too but I always
did feel like I feel like some of you
people the way you're dressed the way
you're looking at me is like you are
also an entertainment and think you can
do this yeah where I don't get that vibe
as much in the East Coast but that's but
that's a minor thing and it's not every
time I find it I find it a comedy scene
I find that the New York comedy scene is
much more gracious when it comes to
Outsiders at first like if I were to go
to New York you know and hit you up you
could get me like five spots
oh no problem you know you could be like
hey we're coming we're going you know
yeah it's not like that in LA no it's
not all I did there's a very few spots
and it's like I can't just go to like at
the Comedy Store and be like yo can we
get they'll be like are you kidding me
look who's coming and anything it's
different like you know there is more
comedy in New York right there's more
clubs there's more places to do it what
but I find it more friendly it is
friendly there I I will say though it's
as you know we we've now kind of been
like oh [ __ ] we got to do these podcasts
and it seems like in the podcasting
stand-up community out in LA it's all
love doing each other shows sharing it
oh god sharing clips because I mean it's
not even close the numbers that your
guys podcast get versus what our
podcasts get like nobody sells tickets
there
Salty's may be the only one that sells
tickets like some of the LA guys out
here like you guys like we like it takes
a lot of work like I just started
selling tickets four months ago and you
know like I just started we're like I
know la the pod can I just started and
it's like exploding on these shows yeah
and and you know Joe Rogan's out here
and all those big big mom
big things and you know hanging out at
the calm like you hang out at the Comedy
Store you're hanging out with guys that
collectively can you could speak to 2030
million people off your guys podcast
where we're hanging out in Comedy Cellar
it's like we're all you know you got the
big guys and they're great but it's like
you know some of the comedians take the
bus they're like nobody has Tesla's in
off the Comedy Cellar
you know we're on the roof taking the
bus we're sitting on the floor you know
David tells sitting on the steps smoking
cigarettes yeah oh he's a genius but
it's like we're not none of us really
need that [ __ ] Comedy Cellar meal
free meal to do a spot you know what
guys are doing well well do you feel
like your dream has changed since you
came into comedy
I feel like now yes I feel like when I
first started all I wanted to do was
have a sitcom like a shiny glossy
Everybody Loves Raymond yeah sitcom and
tell a story about my dad and now all I
want is to tell an honest story about my
dad so I don't care if it's animation I
don't care if I put it on YouTube
I just want my comedy to be seen and
heard by as many people as possible I
don't there's no aspiration to get on
SNL anymore there's no aspiration to do
a sitcom if those things happen they
happen but the aspirations are gone when
I have to what I do when I am learning
the hard way though is with podcasting
because it's so free and you know we're
in your apartment right now it's just
like two dudes talking and you forget
like this could be this is going to be
downloaded by hundreds of thousands or
plus people like some of the stories oh
let's hope some of the stories I tell
like you know like I've said things on
big podcasts about like family members
or said stories and like I'm not saying
their names and then these people are
like yo what the [ __ ] dude why did you
say that yo I got so many people coming
up to you at my job being like is that
true and then I'm like oh [ __ ] so I'm
learning that or even like what happened
to us his name Vanessa now
yeah it's like you know we're on this
we're having this intimate moment we
think like oh just my fans are gonna
watch this it doesn't matter you might
say something off the cuff or a little
off-color right and next thing you know
you're going for a job and then they're
pulling up the clip like yeah you know
you said this on this show
so I'm jealous yeah you're right after
that though after that happened with
Shane I found myself thinking about it
right I was like I guess I can't just
say whatever the [ __ ] I want on my
podcast right yeah well you wonder me
and you can't because it used to be like
oh you put it on YouTube and it's free
you could say but yeah everybody's
watching that now so you know people
aren't you not only people watching but
YouTube is trying to act like a TV
network to where if your content is in
if you're saying things that they don't
want you could curse or whatever but if
you're they'll they'll take the ads off
that you cannot monetize it yeah and so
now there's other but the other networks
are starting like these little off-color
ones that are being like well we're
gonna be the where you could go right
you know there's like you know what I
mean
yeah no I think um so I think might not
that my dream has changed I well I mean
my life has changed you know being a
father first and right so it's like I
got like I I came out like very rarely
will I leave New York for not you know
the right time time and money have
become equal currencies to me now so now
you know I came out here like you know
came out two days I was cuz I gotta go
to Vegas to do that Jimmy Kimmel thing
on Thursday press you know what I'm
gonna find in the West Coast let me get
out here hit these LA I'm taking two
days away from my daughter and not
making any money but the hope is and I
come back with the cachet of fans that
leads to the long run so um I thought
and it's like my age and her manager
would tell me hey don't do that there's
no point to do that or wait to you have
a special second oh I want to keep
coming out here and talking to these
fans and being a part of this because we
can all share the fans I think sometimes
in New York there's like this little
mentality like oh I don't want to tell
so-and-so how I did that because then
they'll take it from me it's like no we
won't shut up
we're also what you're all part of the
same thing we all help if we all get if
one of us gets big we all get big yeah I
do feel like there's more of that here
with the people because I've seen these
guys go from like you know zero to 60
it's it's crazy what did he do before
comedy why was his working at a school I
had a whole different life teacher yeah
I had a whole different life plan I
thought I was gonna do this and then
it's just like all blew up and I was
like you know I don't I just didn't want
to wake up 50 like I didn't follow my
dreams yes you know because that's
really what happens to people they don't
follow their dreams II you know they
they end up like fear stops people from
doing things yeah I don't wanna yeah
it's like oh you know or you become a
slave to things in your life that you
don't know how to control and for some
people it's like having kids or having a
relationship and then they feel like
well now I can't do some people let that
stop them other people go because I have
this I need to work extra hard at this
other thing that's what happened to me
man what because obviously of course you
know when I had this child and you know
my career was just getting started
even my own agent was like hey man like
I don't know if you want to have that
baby like this I mean this makes things
so hard my friends are like way to go
you just [ __ ] got on TV and now now
you have this baby and I got to be
honest with you having my daughter was
not only the best thing that ever
happened to me because of her and
getting to know her and how much he
changed my life
but for career stuff I've never worked
hard in my life because I'm working for
so much more outside of myself not that
I was ever an inherently selfish person
but like you know I live my life to pay
my rent and to do things that I wanted
to do I would still give money to the
homeless or whatever I'm not a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] but I was just living for
me but now to live for her and think
about her and her needs like I very
rarely say yes to something that I
regret I always I'm being selective
about I'm gonna say yes to this because
I've thought it out because it's time
away from her it's money that she can or
can't have so I'm like where I used to
just be very and I've noticed like I'm
you know financially in the best shape
I've ever been with actually doing the
least amount of shows so because I'm
saying yes to the things that matter and
when I when I say notice something's not
like I just sit there and play video
games or dick off I'm writing I'm I'm
thinking about how I could make my
podcast better I might stand up better
or going out and living a day with her
and then that turns into material so I
think with having a child for me it like
I would it change it was like that sink
or swim thing and I was like I'm gonna
swim because if I don't because then
they make it the exam it was like I if
I'm not gonna go 100 percent into comedy
now that I have a child then I might as
well go back to being a physical
therapist take that safe job because now
there's more people
lives involved but I decided to no no
I'm gonna [ __ ] really make it right
comedy because I need to it's a very
specific choice to like that's a moment
right there there's a moment where you
look at your life and you go - I wanna
just be safe right which is an honest
choice that a lot of people make or do I
want to take a risk a calculated risk
right and really try to achieve even
more for myself and my family yeah and I
that's what I say I take a calculated
risk because I'm not gonna go all-in on
something because it's gonna jeopardize
my daughter's future but I will like you
know I go all-in with things on myself
and I'm gonna say if I'm not gonna do
this 100% if I'm not gonna really focus
on it then I might as well not do it
because one I don't really want my
daughter to like be around the guy who's
half-assing anything I don't want her to
you know cuz that's why the father's so
important it's like she's gonna
hopefully date a guy that has the same I
hope well actually I mean I'm funky
piece of [ __ ] but hopefully like you
know when it comes to like you know like
I don't know that I mean yeah I mean if
you only show her the side of like daddy
provides he works hard you know I'm like
please don't ever let her see my DMS you
know what's funny is that what are we
gonna do in the future like we're living
through something really strange right
now right okay so like so kids are now
because I was I you know you can look at
messages and your DMS and people from
say five six seven eight years ago right
right
girls who were whatever age right 20 21
22 right now
eight years later they got kids and
husbands yeah it's like so hos actually
can become housework so what I'm saying
though is like what are we gonna do with
that stuff you know what I mean like
what are we gonna do with that like you
know like you're like there's moms out
there with hundreds of naked pictures
yes on her phone in her cloud I know
kids are gonna be more savvy as they get
older and next thing you know they're
gonna be like mom
I don't you know it's like what like
what's gonna happen I have you know what
are we gonna do I think it's gonna be
like that first time you know when we
were kids like you know most people have
that story like the first time you saw
your dad's dick in the shower it now
it's gonna the first time you started
dad's dick pic just you just see it and
it's just there and it's something that
you have to talk about you know I think
that it's gonna be that because listen
so you had a lot of big pigs is
basically what you're saying listen I
got a pic floating around the internet
right now I stuck a Verizon FiOS remote
in gray sweatpants and it looks like my
dick and I've sent it out to many women
when they've asked for a dick pic and
multiple in have been like out what if I
tweet this out I'm like listen I'll
[ __ ] retweet it because it's not
actually my dick but it looks enough
like my dick where it's like my daughter
may see that one day and I'm just like
listen daddy was I was drunk
okay mommy was asleep and I stuffed a
Verizon FiOS remote in my pants and I
did that or it's gonna be such a or it's
gonna be such a thing that that's just
how we are like Pete you know maybe we
come from such an old school you know
with it now with the internet keeps
moving and moving and moving so we're
still kind of thinking of like Ohio when
we were kids we didn't have any of this
stuff and this is what was happening but
these kids are gonna have all of this
and more while and even that and even
like this kind of like sexual revolution
where like now you know we were growing
up it was like oh woman you know has two
minds our P's and Q's I would never have
sex on the first date of quarters
slaughter and well now that won't happen
now for a woman has sex on the first
date it's like she's liberated sexually
as a female like girls don't think like
that anymore so it's just things have
just changed you know but see my thought
about that even as you bring that up is
like there's two different thoughts so
you're this thought process of shaming
people because you think it's wrong okay
then you have the extreme of that is to
be like do you know do some [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you you're a powerful but then when
are we gonna get to the point where it's
like it's wrong for anybody to have sex
on the first date I know like there's
things wrong with it that have nothing
to do with gender I know it has to do
with like you know or respect for
yourself and like all right nothing I
don't even gonna say that it just
becomes like if you don't really know
this person don't be surprised if some
[ __ ] happens later right because that's
what happens right you know I mean
that's when you look back and go well I
was uncomfortable or I didn't because
you yeah cuz you had sex with someone
you barely know you don't know them
yes it was awkward it was weird you know
so then you that's what you got yourself
in this weird situation
I know I know that was one of those
things were like yeah like especially
like with comedy you know girls you know
the dm's you know how many one-night
stands you have mean and girls on the
road and then it's like yeah now we live
in this place for like everything was
cool but there's even been times where I
felt uncomfortable and didn't say
anything I'm like I feel bad this girl
just came over but I really wanna have
sex with her I would force myself to do
it bro so it's like as a guy I know that
sounds weird but there's times when I
did no no no it's not weird at all
yeah so glad you said that yeah like I
know exactly what you're talking about
years ago I've been in a situation like
this before it's like you're you you
know they come I never forget this guy
and I say to her I go listen I first of
all was a whole thing for her to get I
kept saying you should just go home
I don't ya know know she wanted to Tom
you know I okay now we're here and I'm
like I don't really you know like now
obligated now I have to [ __ ] this chick
yeah you know I mean it's like so like
don't act like it's but but this is why
I understand when a woman says like she
ended up say blowing a guy or something
right right and then later says you know
I wasn't comfortable but people go with
you why did you do that I get why cuz
you had you felt the pressure of the
situation you felt like and this is what
happened why I say people should be more
careful about what they do is because
you know you've been texting and
tweeting each other you've been DMing
like I want to do this I want to do that
and it's just talk you know for guys I
sometimes I think is different because
if I say I want to do this with you
right that's what I want to [ __ ] do
okay you know sometimes a girl they they
they just say in it like oh you wanna oh
you want to do that to my face I want
that too they don't really mean it
why all right then we get a person we
like remember to watch you're wearing
glasses they're just like well and then
they end up doing whatever somebody
don't want to do with it later comes out
like boy made me feel uncomfortable but
you're like what the [ __ ] I didn't know
I didn't see that but now but that's
because we're we're not taking time to
get to know people we're not taking time
to be personal we're not you know right
it's true it's very very true and
especially even now
you know I saw a study that said the
highest rate of Priene teen pregnancy is
now because of like you said the texting
and snapchat messing histogram messaging
not only that they feel like like after
two weeks of texting constantly it's
like that's like a year or two of
conversation I mean we're texting all
day you feel like I've never met you but
I feel like I've known you my whole life
so we have sex immediately and they
don't know they're they don't know [ __ ]
I don't know that yeah you guys haven't
you ever been texting with someone and
they use you had this sort of connection
whatever and then you just hear their
voice and you're just like yuck or
there's some timber in their voice or
there's some way they're talking about
something you might you start to go I
don't really like this person I thought
I knew them like all of the texting the
three weeks and DMing goes right out the
window because you're like I don't like
you dude there was a girl that I was
texting I'm not lying for like eight
[ __ ] months two years ago eight
months she lived another part of the
country eight-month DMing whatever
sexting all that I finally go to her
city to do a show huh meet her not to
this big deal but she only had seven
fingers she never told me
hey that she literally was missing
drivers open with yes how the [ __ ] we
taxed in this fast
oh because she was going like this she
would as soon as our text I would see
the bubbles on her and I'm like she's
doing that with three less fingers than
me that would infuriate me I was
infuriated when you said and I know
there's this honesty of it because I
said I said I didn't mention it you know
whatever and that's just oh you want to
know about my hands right yeah [ __ ] I
was like you can you could talk like I
sent you like everything I've told you
about my deepest darkest secret you
never told me you got the only uh
[ __ ] two fingers on it's a form one
hand it's a fish yeah then she told me
she's got an accent she got it stuck in
a motorboat which is as a child to open
with that story it's a good story so I
got three and my fingers are gone
yeah and this is what the [ __ ] happened
yeah you know me you don't you know did
she like hey baby
she said literally see hide his hand the
whole time and that's what point did she
pulled it out
I think I kind of only saw it like to be
honest to do I kind of saw it like when
we were having sex in the bedroom like
if we were like you know I was like
going to hold her hand and I was what
the [ __ ] to DES on you yeah that's like
that yeah yeah
do you not see the Elliots until your
[ __ ] if you said what's wrong with you
saw her titties you would think this is
the problem monster I didn't notice her
fingers though you didn't notice I
didn't notice it because she was used to
it she knew had it like you don't know
she knew how to hold yeah she's like
physically not force me honest with you
right after the show we had a great
dinner whoo chilling conversing I was
like really like liked her and I still
she was great but it was like talking
but it was a little bit of like oh I've
known you for eight months and I didn't
know that thing about you which is not a
deal breaker and whatever who cares but
it's like it wasn't I felt a little bit
like you're lying to me it would be nice
to know yeah yeah yeah yeah just like a
little thing about you you know yeah
yeah I think that I don't know I like
you know as your cuz you do you feel
like you and your fame is getting
exponentially boom boom boom so now I
could tell you're a dude it's made a lot
of bad choices so like when you're first
coming up we don't even think about like
the end result that one day I'm gonna be
famous
so like I'm sure you have you ever look
back and be like damn I got a lot of DM
conversations I wish I'll you have
absolutely yeah me got a lot of it I got
a lot of them are a lot alike you know
like man like you know never never
unsolicited but like I'll be like man
like I should I
on the third message she send me your
tits I sent me her I sent my dick like
yeah what am i doing and then I never
spoke to her again
you know like what's just sitting there
and it's just in there but it's kind of
one of those things where it's like what
are you gonna do if it comes up it comes
up I mean lifts listen I know you're
gonna own it everything every girl I've
ever been with like I've wanted to be
with them they've told me they wanted to
be with me and we it's all been fun
never treated anyone with disrespect so
if anyone ever said differently I would
be like that's not true because it's not
true well you know no one to visit you
know we all have a different experience
- there's different levels because again
you're a good-looking guy yeah so you
should you might have a different
experience in other people um
not like traditionally handsome okay I
got no you're like I I can't I could
talk a good game I'm interesting so if I
you know I was at you like percent your
wifey material
a hundred son I get it I'm gonna take
care of you you know okay so I have to
flirt you get I'm saying so I I have to
in the past when I was single I gotta
make the first move
got it you know I saw but sometimes
that's gonna be like well I'm not
interested right but but out of context
right that's gonna look crazy right
I that's what that's why I like about
like DMing and all this kind of [ __ ] cuz
now I look back on it cuz you know why
see something happened to me so I'm in
Chicago right walking out of this club I
just did whatever their club in Chicago
and I say nice a nice just different his
thing is I'm on the street you know some
guy walks up he's a little drunk is like
hey man you know like you know my team's
like talk about his girl yeah you know
you tried to [ __ ] my girl when you were
in whatever and he had the DMS [ __ ] he
was showing and we remember his girl
know who his girl is and he show me the
[ __ ] and I'm like whoa listen I didn't
know she had well you think I knew
that's on your girl don't come at me but
I think he knew that that's why he was
like he wasn't angry he was just but
what these chicks will do is they're
gonna use it for their advantage to like
you know is that young well you know
look who's trying to [ __ ] me right dude
how do you could do one better or worse
actually this was six months ago
uh-huh right Saturday morning 9 a.m. my
daughter was with her mom Sunday morning
9 a.m. I get a knock on my door I
thought it was you know whatever who
couldn't even think who could be I
thought maybe I delivered something
wrong delivery some dude look like
frazzled as [ __ ] like Raggedy he goes
are you Chris I said yeah he goes you've
been [ __ ] my wife and I was like whoa
and it was one of those like
split-second decisions I was like I can
either try to attack this guy or
defendant attack or try to disarm it and
it just I was just woken up and I just
was like what's going on and I invited
him into my home which I know is [ __ ]
crazy no it's not I know as a comic by
the way yeah you make quick assessments
of people right so you already assess it
you look if you were to terminate
it would be like not a threat did you
know you know that he had a certain
level of like what he was dealing with
yeah the fact that he came to your place
in the first place he didn't come with
violence he was just like he was upset
but he probably was just like as a man
like - you're [ __ ] my wife so that's
all that white well no because I live in
an apartment building so he came in and
found my actual apartment so I knew he
knew exactly where I live so but I just
was like the only way to disarm this is
I felt like let me talk to him because I
would never willingly have sex with
somebody's wife right so like I knew for
a fact that I did it
no I was assuming that I probably did
have sex with this woman but I didn't
know that she was mad right and then and
then he starts telling me who it is
shows me the DMS I swear for literally
30 seconds I had no idea who this woman
was even looking at the messages of
course cuz that's your game yes your
move yeah I was like I don't know this
ladies and then he and then he show me
the messages and then he showed me a
couple of pictures for I still don't
know who it is right and then he showed
me one that was more recent was like oh
I remember when I had sex with this
woman and then I pulled up my DMS where
I pulled up my Instagram I should say
huh she has a completely different
Instagram with just her and her ass out
and her alright and then he shows me her
real dm's uh her real Instagram and it's
her him the children Oh on the beach all
that and I felt so disgusted and so like
I not and I just told to do it honestly
and he believed me I was like cuz I was
the truth I was like I had no idea I had
no [ __ ] idea that this was your you
also weren't trying to find out either
you didn't ask for a dossier you didn't
get a background check what you were
just like you ready to go I'm gonna go
and this is what I'm saying before about
that's what the problem essage to me but
then looking back those messages she
messaged me like oh you know I talked on
some podcast about being a single dad
she's like I'm a single mom
oh so it's all about her and then and
then because you know but then I learned
my lesson
I had messaged this woman on like the
10th message
I admit cuz she was like want to have
sex right away I messaged her my address
and my apartment on the so I didn't know
that's how he had it look backwards he
telling you exactly where I live so I'm
like I let this random complete stranger
get it into my actual apartment there's
a part of that guy as he's reading
you've done that too yeah there's a part
of that that this guy sees that you're
it wasn't your fault right but there was
just but he can't he loves the woman
still right that's what I tell he loves
her he's not trying to like he's just
like he needs something right cuz what
are you doing that situation you need
something but that's what I'm saying
like so now you have like man it's just
and then he kept texting me and
messaging me yes sir and I said I'm Jose
Gabriel I wish you all the best I'm
starting to happen like but I can't
really take this any further
yeah who's like maybe I'll catch you at
a show and I was like I wouldn't feel
comfortable you came to my shells to let
him know I was like I know I mean no
disrespect by that but I said it's an
awkward situation yeah I said I gave you
100% of the information I have and I
told you how bad I feel not knowing but
I said leave it at down he just wrote
cool he walked cool bro dude I just had
like a recent this is like more recent I
I it I was my girl and I we had broken
up okay so I'm talking to this girl just
DM whatever and it gets a little
whatever right away where she's like
sending videos of herself naked like you
know yummy alright you know so I'm like
okay I'm like okay we're talking though
right you know and then the next thing
you know I see on her thing just and her
stories there's she's got a kid okay
so like oh you got a kid so then there's
a guy also always and I go oh that's
obviously you're the baby daddy right
right yeah look like y'all are to get no
we're just really good friends right
we're like best friends now here we go
ten years we're best friends and so you
know she wants to have lunch and we but
never happens and she gave me this weird
thing about like I can't have her phone
number cuz she only gives her phone
number they're like I at the time I
should have been like of course this is
like would ridiculous she gave me this
whole thing about like only personal and
then it DM like you know and I'm the old
guy who doesn't understand so I went
along with that cuz I was like arguing
with robotics I think it's stupid how
people feel about social media you know
I mean right you know anyways alright
dude the talkee talkee i'm stop texting
stupid [ __ ] you know right you know I
mean she's saying cutesy whatever you
know I get a message from the guy you
know yep he's like I saw your corny ass
messages
[Laughter]
I saw your corny corny ass messages to
my girl boom boom boom
and I'm like bro first of all I didn't
know that was your girl I'm telling him
she told and then she's like I didn't
know you she told me y'all just friends
yeah none of me and he's getting crazy
and then I just go I'm out and I block
them both no but I just was like dude
people are scandalous out there hell
yeah
there just is what I'm saying though is
like just to get back to the to bring in
full circle is that even if you're
having what you assume is an intimate
conversation with someone that you think
well I'm really getting to know this
person I'm really wow this is I have a
feel of connection you don't have a
connection until you are in front of
that person do you hear their voice to
you look in their eyes and at that
moment you're starting something that is
even more deeper and more important than
right this superficial what we think
we're pretending and then after
physically going on a few dates are
marked with finally starts back okay I
can block my cart down that's why I
personally I would much rather I've been
single now for two years two and a half
years had my fun did everything that we
were talking about and now I'm like yo I
want a girlfriend I want to just like
make something work where I have a
relationship a-holes and whatever
happens there happens but at least it's
just one woman cuz this it feels like
with all this energy spending responding
to all these DMS all [ __ ] here at ATC I
come to my show yeah it's it's
inevitably going to either one or two
things gonna happen it's gonna spin out
of control and my health or career is
gonna suffer somehow because I'm not
focusing or whatever or you're gonna run
in to that crazy girl that's gonna try
to take your whole world down yeah it's
a numbers game right I feel like the
house always wins
you could get away with it a thousand
times but then a thousand and one you
get that girl pregnant you get that STD
that girl is crazy and tweets out your
dick pics and then that negates the
previous thousand right you're just
[ __ ] yeah man so it's just numbers
more - I love my girl you know good now
that's why I'm ring shopping and I
wasn't like and I know because the thing
you were saying about your daughter and
like how you're working I'm starting to
feel that about my girl I'm starting
like I want to start thinking about the
future I don't wanna like have a family
and I want to make sure I'm working hard
for myself and for her to make sure
she's happy and make sure that I'm happy
and it's a whole other it's a whole
other way of thinking that's somebody
that's like you know that's single and
like you know you're doing your own [ __ ]
now it's like you everything has a
purpose made me work harder on my
podcast makes me like you know you know
what I'm sayin and it's just this is
just like you know my feeling it doesn't
mean anything but it's like for me you
know I'm 35 now you know I'm somebody's
dad it's a little bit of a whack look
for me now I think to be single like
it's like you know like my kid's mom has
a boyfriend that you know they're great
so happy and then like when my daughter
comes by my house it's like I'm single
like you we eat off styrofoam plates you
know like we're always ordered pizza cuz
I'm like just a single guy like you know
I could feed myself except I don't cook
I don't yeah that's a woman's touch
method or about to say this yeah
something about a woman's touch that
changes your whole say yeah like I know
your girl doesn't live here coz I
stepped through your laundry yeah like I
literally forget it to your house back
room like we step through your whole
laundry that was just all over the floor
[Laughter]
like you [ __ ] rat yeah but you know
it's funny cuz she wants to move in she
I'm telling her she's already like well
we have to do this this and this I hate
your couch I hate it you know she's
right and she said like it's funny how
she said it dude cuz I was like well she
was just couched it you know that's her
parents place to get you know I'm like
no it's too hard no on that and she was
like I guess it's not I was like oh [ __ ]
she's already liking you know like I had
to change the shower heads I had to like
you know but they do make him the
improvements are you really worth it of
course you know you know I I I'm totally
like once you get out of that single
guys date of like Ana stuff
furnace of like this is how it's gonna
be because this is my castle
once you get past all that you just cook
yeah what do you want to do yeah that's
why I got has to have a groom this is
gonna be my room this is my cave I'm
gonna with the [ __ ] I want out here but
you gave every other room right what
pictures you want to take them whatever
you want you do whatever the [ __ ] you do
I don't care oh yeah
make the bed as girly as you want I
realize it's like you know that's what
happy life happy wife yeah it's
beautiful
I know I want that now I don't I I'm
done [ __ ] being single you know says
that cut to like dude we've done a solid
hour I feel like I could talk to you for
like you know another hour so when
you're in town again
you know you'll please you have an open
invitation to come on weather even when
you plug in stuff or whatever like that
we I'm even trying to do like FaceTime
like I'm trying to like you're a big
figure that out too so you're always
welcome to come back on there and I
really appreciate you know everything
that you've been talking about right now
a very insightful guy yeah and a good
father and I appreciate your energy and
I'll have all of Chris's information in
the description there is there anything
that you want to like what what what was
what important thing you got coming out
that you really want to talk about what
is coming out probably like in the next
two weeks next two weeks either this
week coming up or next week so you go I
got a podcast called history hyenas
doing very well we got a live show March
19 to the Gramercy Theater first show
sold out so we got tickets for the
second show and then April 29th the wall
struck Wall Street Theatre in Norwalk
Connecticut and then my own stand-up
days Christie comedy dot-com Chris D
comedy calm Vancouver Boston
Philadelphia Providence we just put up a
Landon Theatre in Neptune theatre in
October got a whole bunch of dates
Newark got a Victoria Theatre in Newark
New Jersey April 18 so Chris D comedy
calm all my stand-up dates and I
appreciate it yeah come check out Chris
D it cuz if I you said Chris D just like
people
anyways guys this has been written with
Griffin continue to watch subscribe
share check out all of his information
go to Eric Griffin calm and
see you next week
[Music]